MUCH FOR YOUR EXCELLENT
REPORTING.
>>> I WANT TO BRING IN THE STATE
ATTORNEY FOR PALM BEACH COUNTY
DOWN IN FLORIDA, DAVE EHRENBERG.
SO GIVE US YOUR SENSE.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THE VERDICT,
$45.2 MILLION IN PUNITIVE
DAMAGES.
>> WOLF, IT IS A BIG VICTORY FOR
THE PLAINTIFFS WHO HAVE SUFFERED
FOR SO LONG AT THE HANDS OF THIS
BELIEVY ATING WIND BAG.
A LOT OF US WITH DISAPPOINTED IN
THAT $4.1 MILLION IN
COMPENSATORY DAMAGES.
SO I WAS EXPECTING A HAMMER TO
COME DOWN TODAY AND IN PUNITIVES
AND IT DID.
$45.2 MILLION.
NOW IT MAY BE REDUCED BY THE
STATUTORY CAP IN TEXAS.
BUT IT IS STILL A VICTORY.
IT IS NOT OVER.
BECAUSE THERE ARE TWO MORE
TRIALS JUST LIKE THIS WHERE HE
COULD ALSO GET HIT WITH BIG TIME
DAMAGES AND THEN THERE IS THE
POSSIBILITY THAT PROSECUTORS
COULD FILE CHARGES AGAINST ALEX
JONES FOR PERJURY.
IT TAKES RARE TALENT TO TURN
YOUR CIVIL TRIAL INTO A CRIMINAL
ONE.
SO HIS LEGAL PROBLEMS ARE NOT
OVER.
>> I WANT TO BRING IN JOEY
JACKS.
THE JUDGE COULD CAP THESE
DAMAGES AS DAVE JUST SAID.
YOU COULD EXPLAIN WHY AND WHAT
THAT POTENTIALLY COULD MEAN FOR
THESE PARENTS.
>> YEAH, YOU KNOW, AT THE END OF
THE DAY, WOLF, THIS IS OBVIOUSLY
A BIG DEAL.
I THINK THE JURY SPOKE.
THEY SPOKE MASSIVELY.
AND SO THE PUNITIVE DAMAGE AWARD
REALLY DEALT WITH THE ISSUE OF
HOW HORRIFIC THESE LIES WERE AND
HOW IT IMPACTED AND EFFECTS THIS
PARTICULAR FAMILY AND CERTAINLY
HE HAS A COUPLE OF OTHERS TO GO
THROUGH.
BUT THIS STATUTORY CAPS AND WHAT
THAT MEANS IS THAT DIFFERENT
JURISDICTIONS LIMIT THE AMOUNT
OF PUNITIVE DAMAGES.
WHAT THEY DO THAT FOR IS THEY DO
THAT SO IT PREVENTED RUINOUS
LIABILITY.
SO YOU DON'T TAKE DOWN ANY
PARTICULAR COMPANY.
SO WHILE A JURY COULD AWARD 45,
$44 MILLION, $100 MILLION, THE
STATUTORY CAP WOULD LIMIT IT TO
A SPECIFIC AMOUNT OF DAMAGES
SUCH THAT NOT THIS PARTICULAR
BUSINESS, IT WASN'T AIMED FOR
THIS AT ALL, IT WAS AIMED FOR
THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY IN
GENERAL.
TO RECOGNIZE THAT PEOPLE COULD
HAVE RELIEF, HOWEVER THAT RELIEF
NOTWITHSTANDING THE JURY'S
FEELINGS, THOUGHTS AND VIEWS AND
BELIEFS AND HERE WE KNOW WHAT
THOSE VIEWS ARE.
IT DOESN'T RUIN A PARTICULAR
COMPANY AND THAT IS WHAT IT
MEANS TO HAVE A STATUTORY
LIMITATION OR CAP AS IT RELATES
TO PUPIVE DAMAGES.
>> AND THE FAMILY ATTORNEY
ACCUSED JONES OF HIDING HIS
WEALTH BY FILING FOR BREAKING
NEWS -- FOR BANKRUPTCY DURING
THE COURSE OF THE TRIAL.
>> I THINK JUSTICE DELAYED WON'T
BE JUSTICE DENIED.
YOU HAVE COME IN WITH CLEAN HAND
AS AND THAT MEANS THAT YOU CAN'T
DISSIPATE ASSETS OR HIDE OR
REMOVE ASSETS IN AN EFFORT AND
ATTEMPT TO STIFLE OR MISDIRECT
OR MISAPPROPRIATE, NOT ALLOW
PEOPLE TO GET THEIR MONEY.
SO WHILE I THINK THAT IT WILL
HAVE SOME EFFECT, BECAUSE THE
FAMILY WILL BE LOOKING WHERE
THOSE ASSETS ARE, THAIL BE
TRYING TO MAKE AN ASSESSMENT AS
TO HOW THEY GET THEM.
I THINK THAT ULTIMATELY IF THE
DAMAGES WERE DISSIPATED IN A WAY
THAT WAS FRAUDULENT, THEY WERE
DISSIPATED IN A WAY THAT WAS AN
ATTEMPT TO DENY RELIEF THAT
THOSE ASSETS ABOUT LE GOTTEN AND
THERE IS OTHER ISSUES AS DAVID
MENTIONED.
THE CRIMINAL ASPECT IS HERE WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE, THE
JANUARY 6, THERE IS SO MUCH THAT
EMANATED FROM THIS.
MUCH MORE THAN MONEY.
>> DAVE, LET ME GET YOUR
THOUGHTS ON THAT AS WELL.
THE FACT THAT JONES WAS FILING
FOR BANKRUPTCY DURING THE COURSE
OF THE TRIAL.
>> SOMETHING REALLY NEEDS TO BE
DONE ABOUT BANKRUPTCY ABUSE IN
THE COUNTRY.
HE IS NOT THE FIRST ONE TO DO IT
AND HE WON'T BE THE LAST.
ATTEMPTS TO HIDE YOUR MONEY,
THERE IS EVIDENT THAT HE STARTED
TO TAKE AWAY $11,000 A DAY FROM
HIS COMPANIES TO HIDE IT AFTER
HE GOT HIT WITH THE DEFAULT
JUDGMENT.
AND SO SOMETHING NEEDS TO BE
DONE ABOUT IT.
AND AGREE WITH JOEY, JUSTICE
WILL BE DELAYED BUT NOT DENIED.
I THINK PLAINTIFFS WILL GET
THEIR MONEY AND AGAIN THERE ARE
MORE PLAINTIFFS LINED UP IN THE
NEAR FUTURE TO SUE HIM AND GET A
BIG RECOVERY.
>> WELL ON THAT POINT, JOEY,
THIS IS THE FIRST OF WHAT, THREE
TRIALS FOR DAMAGES AGAINST
JONES.
WHAT COULD FUTURE TRIALS
POTENTIALLY YIELD?
>> I THINK THEY'LL YIELD MORE
RELIEF FOR FAMILIES IF YOU COULD
CALL IT RELIEF.
WHEN YOU LOSE A YOUNG ONE WHO IS
SO INSTRUMENTAL, IT IS LIFE
ITSELF.
ANY PARENT WOULD GIVE THEIR LIFE
FOR THEIR CHILD AND WHEN YOU
HAVE THESE CONSPIRACY THEORIES
THAT ARE OUT THERE THAT IT IS
FAKE AND HOME AND THE PARENTS
ARE ACTORS NONE OF US COULD
IMAGINE HOW IT IMPACTS A FAMILY
EMOTIONALLY AND OTHER WISE.
I'M SURE THEY'RE JUST DEEPLY
DEPRESSED ABOUT THIS AND YOU
HAVE HIM OUT THERE SPEWING THIS
HATRED SO I THINK THERE WILL BE
ACCOUNTABILITY IN THE OTHER
TRIALS AND THAT ACCOUNTABILITY
WILL LOOK MUCH LIKE IT DID HERE,
WITH A JUROR COMING BACK WITH
COMPENSATORY DAMAGES AND THEN
PUNITIVE DAMAGES WHICH ARE
DESIGNED TO PUNISH TO SEND A
MESSAGE THIS IS JUST NOT
SOMETHING THAT YOU SHOULD BE
DOING AND IT WILL SLOW HIM DOWN
AN NOT ONLY THAT, BUT DETER
OTHERS WHO MIGHT SPEW SUCH
HATRED AND SUCH NEGATIVITY AND
SUCH FALSEHOODS ABOUT